bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france on va parler du coc vide
rapidement la france qui bat tous les
records de contamination en europe ce
serait surtout liée aux contaminations
dans les écoles selon les experts la
faute à la politique d'ouverture à tout
prix de jean michel blanquer et deuxième
question faut-il reporter du coup les
les épreuves du bac selon-vous anthony
gratacos
bonjour mais c'est vous la change monde
auto cole incessants jean michel planté
ne cesse de faire des annonces mais ça
change pas les 7 dernières semaines mais
je crois que le problème a surtout été
là c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas eu de
cohérence dans l'organisation de la
l'intérieur des établissements scolaires
contre le coc vide
avec seulement sur ce statut de la
france qui bat tous les records de
contamination en europe il ya plusieurs
choses déjà on est le pays qui testons
plus donc mécaniquement qu'on conteste
le plus qu'on trouve un petit peu plus
de contamination il ya une forme de
rationalité après on constate une
flambée total sur les écoles et de
manière incontrôlée nous on avait
proposé choses soient annulées ou
d'ailleurs valérie pécresse la terre
frais également de repousser d'une
huitaine de jours la rentrée scolaire
les protocoles n'était pas prêt on en a
eu la démonstration avec une
présentation en fait dans le parisien en
version payante sur internet par le
ministre le week-end précédant la
rentrée dans les mairies on sait plus
retrouvé à devoir s'adapter comme on
pouvait les enseignants je n'ose même
pas imaginer comment il faudrait alors
des manches soir et le lundi matin il ya
eu un changement de protocole en cours
de semaine parfaite on paye un petit peu
tout ça maintenir l'école ouverte c'est
quelque chose de souhaitable tout le
monde souhaite que l'école reste ouverte
parce que les enfants déjà été
lourdement impactés mais je pense que vu
le niveau d'impréparation la rentrée
scolaire s'était pas raisonnable de ne
pas décaler d'une semaine voilà donc on
paye un petit peu ce phénomène là
heureusement heureusement le virus mais
on semble moins virulent que son
prédécesseur le delta emmanuel macron
qui
on vient de le voir un fait durer le
suspense encore sur sa candidature hier
dans la creuse le chef de l'état a dit
qu'il se prononcerait le temps venu il
est en baisse dans les sondages emmanuel
macron est-ce que c'est judicieux
d'attendre selon-vous anthony gratacos
non mais c'est un faux débat à chaque
élection présidentielle quand le
président est en situation de se
représenter on connait le nez des bars
françois mitterrand 1988 jacques chirac
en 2002 nicolas sarkozy en 2012 c'est le
problème c'est le régime politique c'est
qu'à partir du moment où on est dans un
système présidentiel
il est compliqué vaut le président de
descendre de son piédestal pour aller
faire campagne et rentrer dans l'arène
avec les autres candidats tout en
continuant de gouverner le pays mais ça
c'est notre régime
de monarchie élective
qui qui qui pose ce problème donc je
soutiens pas emmanuel macron mais je ne
fais que constater qu'il fait ce que
tous les autres candidats à leur
réélection ont fait et j'ai pas de doute
et je pense que les français ont donc
pas de doute sur le fait qu'il sera
candidat à sa réélection et les départs
alors que les débats sont en train
d'être organisées pour les pour les
candidats le chef de l'état lui a fait
savoir qu'il ne participerait qu'il ne
participerait pas au débat du premier
tour at-il raison ou tort jean philippe
dugoin clément
visiblement mais sur un bon président ou
jupiter n'aime pas tellement débattre
avec le club non mais ce qui est ce qu a
pu m'en fous cette semaine il a
ridiculisé la france c'est la première
fois que ça arrive il est au parlement
européen il refuse de répondre aux
questions des journalistes les
journalistes ont quitté la salle c'est
la première chose
est derrière la tradition veut qu'au
parlement européen le président de
l'europe est une conférence de presse
répondent aux questions de journalistes
il a refusé de répondre aux questions du
journaliste et journalistes sont partis
dire qu'il a refusé de répondre aux
journalistes européens il refusé
d'expliquer les positions qui étaient
celles du président de l'union
européenne pour six mois c'est quelque
chose qui est passé complètement sur les
radars en france mais qui est
extrêmement grave et là on est sur la
même chose on est sur jupiter au sommet
de l'olympe qui ne va pas aller débattre
qui est candidat tout le monde le sait
mais qui ne se déclarent pas pourquoi
parce que s'il se déclarait une fois
obligé d'ouvrir ses comptes de campagne
d ouvrir ses dépenses électorales que
ces temps d'antenne seraient
comptabilisés et donc aujourd'hui il a
tous les avantages sans aucun
inconvénient d'être en campagne
électorale donc il va faire durer le
plaisir autant tinto et effectivement
c'est quelqu'un qui ne souhaite pas
débattre parce que accepté de débattre
c'est d'une certaine manière à accepter
de se mettre à égalité avec ses
adversaires avec ses concurrents et
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qu'il ne
veut pas il ya un régime ultra
présidentielle qui donne une force qui
donne une imprimante sûrs médiatique
absolument colossal au président de la
république sortant ils le souhaitent
pour sortir que ça au fond est assez
hypocrite et une certaine forme ni
l'égalité entre les candidats quel qu'il
soit quel que soit leur choix politique
quelle que soit leur valeur mais ces
avantages au président dans ce système
françois hollande n'a pas exclu de se
présenter à regarder
est ce qu'une candidature de plus serait
utile je ne sais pas je ne pense pas
d'ailleurs j'ai les mêmes idées qu'avant
je continue à les défendre et un ancien
président peut très bien refaire de la
politique et c'est arrivé être candidat
à l'élection présidentielle
je vais en tout cas prendre la parole
bientôt un thonier greta caussade
hidalgo dit que ces deux mais moi vous
êtes d'accord ou pas
ah non je pense pas je crains que
françois hollande soit très sérieux et
il se dit que
il est pas certain qu'ils les lisent
aimé qu'ils voudraient serait impliqué
dans la vie parlementaire et qui
pourrait être candidat aux élections
législatives en corrèze donc a priori il
veut se réinvestir dans le champ
politique je suis pas sûr que ce soit
une bonne idée vu le bilan qui nous a
laissé après cinq ans à les utiliser je
ne vois pas ce qui peut apporter dans le
débat
et
il y avait eu un sondage en cas de
candidature et il fait deux fois moins
qu anne hidalgo a priori je crois pas
que ce soit souhaitable pour la gauche
vu l'état dans lequel on se trouve
aujourd'hui avec un éclatement des
candidatures et aucun candidat qui
profite d'une réelle dynamique et qui
est en position de se retrouver au 2e
tour pour le moment il y en a pas un qui
passe la barre des 10% ou qui se
stabilise un score à peu près correct et
qui est en capacité de rassembler son
camp je crois pas que françois hollande
après son bilan de calamiteux le sera
plus que les autres ont fait le tour de
l'actualité politique il ya cette
question combien important du pouvoir
d'achat des français avec les prix de
l'essence qui bat de nouveaux records
alors que le chèque énergie et dont est
aujourd'hui octroyés aux chômeurs le
gouvernement doit-il mettre en place des
mesures supplémentaires sans philippe
dugoin clément
je considère que le pouvoir d'achat est
très certainement le sujet majeur
centrale et durable de cette campagne
présidentielle il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui viennent ponctuellement la
question de la capacité de nos
concitoyens à garder le niveau de vie
quelle heure à le conserver et a espéré
d'améliorer ses justes fondamentale on
assiste depuis plusieurs mois à une
explosion du prix de l'essence et du
prix de l'énergie en général on est sur
des facteurs qui vont continuer à
augmenter sur l'essence ou doit
impérativement jouer sur la question de
la taxation on est le pays qui taxant le
plus avec un système d'ailleurs où on
est un peu le niveau de taxation peut
encore le prix augmente naturellement le
jeu de surtaxation augmente les recettes
de l'état il y avait eu un système de
tei pp paulo tente qui avait été mis à
une époque en place pour permettre de
limiter les hausses quand il y en avait
je le dis d'autant plus facilement que
ça n'était pas ma famille politique
était aux affaires à cette époque là
mais c'est un système nourrisson
reconnaître pour les choses marchent qui
est bien pire que d'être sectaires dans
la vie c'est quelque chose qui
permettait d' écraser les hausses alors
en sens inverse qui ne répercutaient pas
intégralement les baisses mais qui
permettait de détecter neo et si on ne
met pas ce genre de système en place
quand on est là on va faire des chèques
de 100 euros avec ce qui représente pas
forcément grand chose avec des
sentiments d'injustice entre les gens
qui bénéficient ceux qui en bénéficient
pas ceux qui en bénéficient alors que
potentiellement ils ont des êtres
d'entreprise alors que d'autres n'en
bénéficient pas alors qu'il n'a aucune
dette d'entreprises enfin ça part d'un
bon sentiment un peu électoraliste on va
dire les choses quand même à trois mois
d'une élection quand on envoie des
chèques de 100 euros à des électeurs
potentiels mais on aura pas résolu le
problème sur le fond anthony gratacos
vous êtes d'accord avec ce que dit jean
philippe dugoin clément
oui oui je suis à la fois d'accord sur
le fait que la question du pouvoir
d'achat centrale lors de cette élection
présidentielle et je suis aussi d'accord
et le fait que je peux pas continuer à
distribuer des chèques pour essayer
compenser la hausse du coût de la vie et
qu'il faut réfléchir plus en profondeur
à des systèmes de compensation si vous
voulez ce qui est insupportable
au même moment où que les actionnaires
de ce pays vont toucher 73 milliards
euros dividende ce qui représente un
record que les capitalisations
boursières n'ont jamais été aussi forte
en même temps on s'aperçoit que les
français ont de plus en plus de mal à
vivre et là il ya une injustice de plus
en plus grande dans la répartition des
richesses et ça malheureusement
aujourd'hui à part à gauche on entend
pas vraiment de propositions pour
pouvoir rééquilibrer le système
capitaliste économique et les salariés
les travailleurs gagnent mieux leur vie
et c'est pas simplement en défiscalisant
sur les heures supplémentaires ou en
faisant des chèques on va leur permettre
de mieux vivre la question prioritaire
aujourd'hui on le voit que ce soit dans
la fonction publique ou dans le privé
c'est l'augmentation des salaires on ne
peut pas rester à des niveaux de
salaires aussi bas alors que les prix
augmentent aussi fortement et c'est un
problème qui ne date pas d'hier c'est
récurrent depuis une dizaine d'années
les agriculteurs aussi ont du mal à
joindre à finir leurs fins de mois je
dis ça parce que emmanuel macron est
aujourd'hui en haute vienne il était
hier en déplacement on la vit auprès des
agriculteurs c'est un électorat qui est
courtisé par les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle valérie pécresse était
jeudi dernier dans le doubs au chevet
des agriculteurs écoutez la
je battrai la ghriba chine je vous le
dis solennellement
je condamnerai toutes ces méthodes et la
violence de ceux qui salissent le métier
et l'honneur des agriculteurs et je
resterai la grille fierté voilà les
petites phrases de la campagne
présidentielle je resterai la grille
fierté valérie pécresse qui a également
dit que l'agriculture française était
devenue déficitaire pour la première
fois depuis 1945 les l'agriculture
doit-elle aussi être un thème majeur de
cette campagne jean philippe dugoin
clément oui pour plusieurs raisons d'une
pincée l'indépendance alimentaire du
pays donc c'est quelque chose de
fondamental quand on parle de
réindustrialiser pays d'être moins
dépendant si une des questions posent
d'alcool vides mais assez aussi
conserver notre capacité agricole s'est
accompagné une profession est en
profonde souffrance aujourd'hui dans sa
mutation dans son évolution on ne jure
c'est peu quand on n'est pas dans les
territoires où la souffrance qui est
celle d'agriculteur qui au fond on
l'impression non seulement de ne plus
être reconnu mais que simplement de ne
plus pouvoir exercer leur profession
parce que financièrement ils s'en
sortent plus c'est particulièrement vrai
sur les jeunes exploitants qui ont
encore un modèle économique plus
fragiles avec des emprunts en cours on a
connu plusieurs années avec des
variations extrêmement forte de recettes
d'une année à l'autre il ya un sentiment
de dévalorisation de mépris d'une partie
de la profession qui est très forte et
en fait il ya non seulement le fait de
redonner confiance de rendre à cette
profession l'estiment que le pays lui
doit mais au-delà de ça ça passe aussi
par toute une série de dispositifs dead
d'accompagnement pour leur permettre
tout simplement pouvoir vivre dignement
donc là dessus on a énormément de
propositions avec valérie pécresse de
soutien on pourrait dire dessus
concrètement ça soit la réduction des
cotisations la réduction de la taille de
l'impôt foncier que ça soit également la
réduction des charges sur les contrats
d'apprentissage pour les salariés d des
entreprises agricoles mais on est sur
une profession qui est en souffrance et
en option une profession qu'on ne peut
pas laisser dans cette situation qu'on
parle des céréaliers qu'on parle des
éleveurs
des maraîchers et on est sur une
profession qui surtout va devoir faire
face parce que c'est une attente des
consommateurs parce que c'est une
attente de la société quand on parle de
transition écologique à une mutation une
évolution de son modèle et on ne pourra
pas le faire ou uniquement en tapant sur
les agriculteurs on doit le faire en les
accompagnant en les soutenant et en leur
rendant ce qu'ils ont donné au pays
alors je vais vous laisser aussi vous
exprimer l'action tony gratacos mais
j'aimerais qu'on écoute aussi eric
zemmour qui lui aussi est allé au chevet
des agriculteurs dans la bosse en ce
début d'année regarder
la ruralité c'est la france on a
longtemps favorisé les villes et les
banlieues il faut rééquilibrer les
choses en faveur de la france rurale ma
mesure la plus emblématique est la
version des fonds c'est-à-dire basculer
les fonds de la politique de la ville
vers le développement des régions
rurales avec également les villes
moyennes et petites la gauche aussi a
fait pas mal de propositions anthony
gratacos il faut sauver l'agriculture en
france
oui bien sûr surtout que
des batteurs l'a évoqué à la fin de son
intervention de l'agricul le monde
agricole va avoir une part décisive est
conséquente dans la transition
écologique
qu'il faut absolument qu'on accompagne
nos agriculteurs pour qu'ils puissent
passer cette étape qui est extrêmement
importante c'est une demande des
français et je crois aussi que c'est une
demande du monde agricole il ne l'est
pas aujourd'hui se retrouver seule face
à ce problème le souci c'est que l'état
a déserté le monde rural la disparition
des services publics qui a été commencé
sous le mandat de nicolas sarkozy
la diminution des dotations de
fonctionnement pour les collectivités
qui là aussi a été commencé par le le le
gouvernement de françois fillon a
entraîné une disparition de l'état du
maillage territorial qui existaient qui
était très important en france et qui a
participé largement si l'on dise mais
repart donc plus de cent mille
exploitations qui ont disparu en dix ans
bien sûr et c'est lié aussi à la
spéculation foncière
aux difficultés d'installation des
jeunes agriculteurs qui doit s'en était
très fortement pour pouvoir lancer une
exploitation les problèmes sont
multiples et on ne peut pas les régler
que d'une seule façon ce qui est sûr
c'est que pour pouvoir avancer il faut
absolument que le prochain gouvernement
il intègre les collectivités locales
c'est via les collectivités locales les
communes les départements et les régions
qu'on arrivera à accompagner les
agriculteurs parce que quand on dit le
monde agricole c'est quelque chose qui
est très vaste c'est le petit maraîcher
qui est d'angers commune et c'est aussi
des céréaliers qui sont présents sur des
départements avec des centaines
d'hectares donc il faut absolument que
ceux qui sont sur le terrain qui les
accompagne au jour le jour et les moyens
de les soutenir et qu'il y ait une
politique cohérente et coordonnée sur
l'ensemble du territoire ce qui est loin
d'être le cas aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
faut revoir complètement le modèle
finalement agricole aujourd'hui en
france jean philippe dugoin clément
faut-il redonner de l'argent là de
l'argent trop perçu dans les villes
c'est ce que dit eric zemmour à ce que
ce serait une des solutions non mais ce
que dirait que zemmour est complètement
caricatural c'est de dire on va où va
cesser de faire quelque part pour se
faire ailleurs c'est de dire on va
laisser des quartiers se paupériser
partir à vau l'eau c'est le premier qui
parle de la communautarisation du pays
les dangers de sécessionnisme du pays et
c'est à dire très bien on va finir
d'exclure des quartiers pour aller
essayer de faire un mur mais notre
modèle c'est pas de faire des plus
malheureux pour essayer de sauver
d'autres personnes c'est de faire pour
tous et puis ça veut dire quoi ce que
dit monsieur zemmour on va arrêter la
politique de la ville mais on va les
aider de les villes moyennes ou des
petites villes enfin quand on est à
étendre 25 d'habitants il ya des
quartiers occupés v quand on est à
montereau 20000 habitants il est des
quartiers aux politiques de la ville ça
veut dire quoi on les aide plus on les
soutient plus où c'est des petites
villes et des villes moyennes on
continue quand même à les aider elle en
est sûre d'un affichage politique c'est
ccc à ces malheureux oui il faut aider
d'un remaniement que les bien sûr mais
c'est ce qu'on a fait en ile-de-france
en ile-de-france avec valérie pécresse
on a créé une politique dite de là
ruralité c'est à dire tout simplement
qu'on ne fait pas moins pour les zones
urbaines denses mais qu' on fait la même
chose en termes d'investissements par
habitant en zone rurale ça veut dire
qu'on va soutenir le monde agricole ça
veut dire qu'on met des politiques
particulières de soutien aux communes de
moins de 2000 habitants ça veut dire
qu'on met en place des politiques de
soutien au maintien ou à la création du
commerce dans les communes de moins de
10000 habitants dans les secteurs hors
périphérie
du grand paris c'est ce type de
politique qu'on peut mener mais ce que
je veux dire on ne construit pas une
unité nationale on ne construit pas une
union sans disant on va arrêter d'aider
certains pourrait d ailleurs c'est
stigmatisant et on ne constate pas une
politique en stigmatisant une partie de
la france surprise de la france contre
une autre parti sadi gratacos un mot sur
un phénomène très inquiétant c'est
évidemment le suicide des agriculteurs
il y en aurait deux par jour selon les
chiffres de la mutualité sociale
agricole
605 suicide chez les agriculteurs
ils étaient 2 174
chez les plus de 65 ans le gouvernement
a proposé un plan des nains justement
pour lutter contre ces suicides regardez
ce qu'on dit cette association paysanne
le suicide n'est que la pointe émergée
de l'iceberg de la souffrance au travail
des agricultrices et des agriculteurs il
est urgent d'interroger le modèle
industriel de développement agricole qui
engendre isolement surcharge de travail
alors évidemment tous les candidats ont
des mesures apportées pour améliorer
leur situation et que ne faut-il pas
finalement revoir complètement le modèle
faire un grenelle de l'agriculture
antonio gratacos
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est que la question qui se
pose
elle n'est pas seulement celle des
revenus des agriculteurs
elle n'est pas seulement celle de
l'aménagement du territoire elle est
celle d'un modèle complet
d'un monde agricole qui est très vaste
qui est très différents selon qu'on
fasse de l'élevage de céréales depuis
maraîchage et c est un grenelle on ne
peut pas proposer un grenelle pour
chaque problème
pour le régler mais par contre on doit
avoir un débat dans le pays parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un sujet qu'on met
sous le boisseau et on n'en parle pas ou
alors on en parle dans les milieux
autorisés de corps au niveau local mais
on a pas de débat national sur ce sujet
et moi je ne peux pas vous donner des
solutions toutes faites parce que c'est
vraiment un sujet très compliqué est ce
qu'on devrait aller interroger d'abord
c'est les agriculteurs c'est à eux qu'on
devrait demander quelles sont les
solutions parce que c'est eux qui
connaissent leur métier mais c'est très
compliqué parce que c'est toujours la
même histoire pour qu'ils se fassent
entendre il faudrait qu'ils puissent
s'investir dans le champ médiatique et
politique sauf que ce sont des gens qui
travaillent 50 60 heures par semaine et
qui n'ont pas le temps de d'aller
militer dans des syndicats
des partis politiques donc il faut que
l'état se met en situation de les
entendre de cibler
exactement leurs problèmes et on
construira ensemble les solutions mais
commençons par organiser le débat
une minute je vous la corde puisque vous
n'avez pas eu le même temps de paroles
entonnées gratacos l'europe aussi un met
en place selon son son green deal la pac
a été modifié également elle va être
mise en oeuvre à partir de 2023 est ce
que l'europe et nature et et les mesures
écologiques que son nature à améliorer
le sort des agriculteurs selon vous
l'europe et de l'agriculteur cela prend
ses fortes pour que l'europe avance il
faut que la france soit puissante au
sein de l'europe pour pouvoir influer
sur les politiques européennes sans
pouvoir faire en sorte que l'europe bien
sûr ça coûte cher les colas question est
de savoir quelle est calé quel est le
sauf que nous voulons donner ce qu'on
veut aller vers une durabilité de notre
modèle est ce que nous souhaitons que
l'europe viennent soutenir nos
agriculteurs viennent soutenir nos
exploitants et on pourra très
concrètement le faire que si la france
prend toute sa place dans l'europe est
forte au sein de l'europe et est capable
d'impulser des politiques publiques
c'est lui faisons toujours aujourd'hui
et quand on voit la façon dont tu as
commencé cette semaine la présidente de
l'union européenne française lors qu'une
présence symbolique de six mois c'est
tous les 13 ans des pays préside donc le
travail se fait aussi dans le semestre
avant dans le semestre après et tout au
long de cette période mais le mandat
européen français a bien mal démarré
nous ont demandé de leur qc de six mois
c'était parfaitement faisable pour
éviter de les cornées d'en faire un jeu
politicien avec un présent la république
qui cherche à s'en servir d opposition
qui viennent d'attaquer en transposant
le débat français national à bruxelles
et à strasbourg ça n'a pas été le choix
du présent la république pour des
questions européennes et c'est dommage
et au fond c'est toutes les politiques
européennes en faveur de l'agriculture
mais pas qu'eux qui vont souffrir merci
beaucoup je vois que en tenir à tacos
vous êtes d'accord merci en tout cas à
tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
débat ce matin sur rtl france